comme la ministre la parole est à
monsieur luc chatel
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre le 5 avril
dernier dans cet hémicycle comme
nombreux de mes collègues je vous ai
applaudi je vous ai applaudi parce qu'en
réponse à notre collègue damien abad qui
vous interpeller sur la montée du
fondamentalisme et sur la question du
voile sur le sol de la république
française vous avait réaffirmé avec
force les valeurs de la république
celles que nous partageons la liberté
d'expression la liberté de conscience et
de culte mais aussi la laïcité est la
stricte égalité des hommes et des femmes
sur le sol de la république française
monsieur le premier ministre
ces principes ne saurait souffrir
d'exception
pourtant le 20 avril dernier s'est tenue
à sciences po un rassemblement qui a
considérablement choqué les français
le hidjab des ou deux jeunes filles
voilées ont expliqué leur épanouissement
personnel et les ségrégations dont elle
serait victime sur le sol de la
république française
si vous doutez du caractère prosélyte de
ce rassemblement
je vous encourage à aller sur le site
internet word et déjà des monsieur le
premier ministre votre gouvernement n'a
pas réagi
votre ministre du droit des femmes
interrogées la semaine dernière a
délibérément évité la réponse vous ne
pouvez pas rester silencieux vous ne
pouvez pas mardi et mercredi chaque
semaine nous rappeler les grands
principes républicains auxquels nous
adhérons est resté silencieux lorsque la
république en permanence et testé sur le
territoire monsieur le premier ministre
réagissez au nom de ces valeurs
républicaines
merci monsieur chatel la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre manuel
valls ce président mesdames et messieurs
les députés monsieur le député monsieur
le ministre et ministre de l'éducation
nationale confrontée
bien sûr à à ces questions oui il y à
une montée du fondamentalisme de
l'islamisme radical dans nos sociétés
dans notre société en france tout
particulièrement qui se manifeste sous
différentes formes
bien sûr par sa forme la plus extrême et
ce sont ces français ou ses citoyens
vivent dans notre pays qui vont
combattre en syrie ou en irak pour
préparer aussi des attentats pour tuer
des français comme cela a été le cas par
deux fois en 2015 il y à des milliers de
jeunes ou d'individus qui se sont
radicalisées ce qui nous amène nouveau
gouvernement nous mobiliser une nouvelle
fois et sera amené à faire de nouvelles
propositions pour faire en sorte que nos
dispositifs soit encore plus efficace et
c'est tout le gouvernement qui doit être
mobilisés contre cette radicalité contre
ces processus qui sont particulièrement
inquiétants et qui touche et qui touche
et qui touche monsieur chatel a posé la
question avec méthode
je lui répondrais permettait que je
prenne un instant pour lui répondre et
qui touche profondément non seulement la
société française mais le monde entier
tous les pays sont confrontés de l'autre
côté du globe où je me trouvais il ya
encore quelques heures
c'est le cas aussi et puis il y à ces
phénomènes de prosélytisme que vous
évoquez je condamne avec la plus grande
fermeté le type d'initiative qui s'est
déroulé à sciences po
plusieurs membres du gouvernement se
sont exprimés
sont exprimés initiative initiative qui
a rencontré d'ailleurs peu de succès
mais nous devons être extrêmement
attentifs extrêmement attentive parce
que j'avais souligné à juste titre
combien d ya cela est notamment derrière
la question du voile
moi là dessus j'affirme une position
elle peut mettre personnel je
continuerai à l'affirmer dans le respect
évidemment de toutes les croyances et je
fais la part entre ce qui est la liberté
religieuse et ce qui pour moi un signe
d'asservissement de la femme
et puisque vous avez parler d'égalité
femmes hommes
je veux une nouvelle fois soutenir la
ministre des droits des femmes
parce qu'elle a été mise en cause alors
que l a précisément mis le doigt là où
ça fait mal c'est à dire face à des
groupes à des réseaux sur internet où on
met en cause la liberté même cette
liberté fondamentale
cette égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes
et parce que je combats tous les
fondamentalismes parce que je combats
toutes les identités qui nous amène
précisément à la fracturation de nos
sociétés parce que je pense que la
cohésion sociale et républicaine est
plus que jamais nécessaire parce que
l'école doit jouer un rôle fondamental
et parce que l'université monsieur le
ministre doit être en effet aussi
protéger de ce fondamentalisme je
continuerai ce combat il y à la loi et
nous savons ce qu elle permet et ce
qu'elle empêche
mais il ya le combat politique et
citoyen sur des solutions si je le
mènerai est-ce que je suis persuadé que
nous partageons ces valeurs sur tous les
bancs